yesterday the federal reserve had a
press conference and guess what they
didn't raise interest rates everyone has
been freaking out expecting the fed to
go ahead and not only raise interest
rates but also to begin their tapering
but they didn't do it they're absolutely
full of [ __ ]
so if we go all the way back to march of
2020 there's a public health crisis the
coronavirus is spreading throughout the
world and what do we get in march of
2020 we get the fed and politicians
stepping in with monetary and fiscal
policy they go ahead and they inject
tons and tons of cheap capital into the
market they drop interest rates via two
emergency rate cuts down to zero percent
and they pump trillions of dollars into
the economy all that cheap capital ends
up doing two things it pumps asset
prices to the moon literally the stock
market last year hit an all-time high 70
different times bitcoin hit an all-time
high all asset prices up significantly
the s p 500 up 30 something percent the
real estate market of about 20 bitcoin
up 65 etc that is all asset inflation
going on at the same exact time that
asset prices were going up so were
consumable goods we saw inflation cpi
ended up hitting seven percent in the
united states banana land in terms of
inflation numbers and so ultimately the
fed all of that easing all that cheap
capital ended up leading to a much much
more inflated economy and so they've got
to make a decision are they actually
going to raise interest rates are they
actually going to taper all that
quantitative easing they said they were
they began to talk tough they began to
say take us seriously we're really going
to do it but ultimately what they did
was nothing nothing was changed now of
course they're continuing to talk tough
they're continuing to sing soon many
people are reading into that thinking
that it'll be in march but i don't know
if that's necessarily true and so here's
an exact summary of what
chairman powell said yesterday he said
prepare for a march rate hike maybe
they've been saying that for a while
he believes we're at maximum employment
i don't know why he thinks that we're
still over four percent unemployment
before the pandemic we're at three and a
half percent so we aren't even back to
the pre-pandemic unemployment levels yes
inflation is getting worse duh you don't
have to be a mathematician to realize
that he believes that there will be more
than three rate hikes or at least that
there's a real possibility of that and
he's not worried about markets now
whether you believe them or you don't
ultimately what we are watching is that
there is no free market in the stock
market there's no free market in real
estate et cetera everyone is dependent
on interest rates and the federal
reserve decisions unfortunately the
federal reserve their monetary policy
their interest rate decisions etc it's
all determined by 12 people 12 people
who are not elected by the american
population they simply go into a room
they pontificate based on various data
points that they have and they come out
and they reveal their findings in a
press conference the most antiquated
dinosaur type
process ever so ultimately what you have
to start to think about is what the hell
is the federal reserve going to do and
if you're making your investment
decisions based on that you're not a
long term thinker you're simply worried
about the short term and so cms intern
with some great notes we're not going to
go through all of these but basically
the opening statement is the key piece
here is they want to reduce their net
asset purchases the economy shows great
strength covad is still impacting the
economy health experts showing that omri
con is not as bad inflation is well over
two percent duh economies no longer
needs monetary policy well there's still
gonna be monetary policy it may just not
be loose monetary policy tightening will
occur in the future and it will shrink
the fed's balance sheet in future after
rate tightening [ __ ] i don't believe
that at all here's a quote from jerome
powell chairman of the federal reserve
what he said was inflation risks are
still to the upside in the views of most
fomc participants and certainly in my
view as well there's a risk that the
high inflation we are seeing will be
prolonged there's a risk that will be
move even higher so we don't think
that's the base case but you asked what
the risks are and we have to be in a
position with all monetary policy to
address all the possible outcomes so
they believe there's a real possibility
that inflation at seven percent could go
higher in the short to medium term i got
a second quote where he says in light of
the remarkable progress we've seen in
the labor market an inflation that is
well above our two percent long-run goal
the economy no longer needs sustained
high levels of monetary policy support
that is why we are phasing out our asset
purchases and we expect it will soon be
appropriate to raise the target rage for
the federal funds rate well they can
continue to say all of this they
continue to say they're going to reduce
the fed's balance sheet they continue to
say they're going to raise interest
rates but ladies and gentlemen boys and
girls people around the world here i
present you the fed's balance sheet they
ain't bringing down nothing it's up and
to the right non-stop always they
literally can't taper this nonsense if
you go back to 2008 2009 they had about
900 billion on the fed's balance sheet
now we're closing in on 9 trillion
that's a 10 bagger for those of you
keeping track at home so ultimately the
federal reserve can say that they're
going to raise interest rates maybe they
do maybe they don't but it's going to be
a small rate increase and it's going to
be short-lived because the second they
start to raise rates the markets get
shaky they could potentially get closer
and closer to bankrupting our country
and ultimately what we are living in is
a zero rate environment where they have
to return back to zero interest rates
over time on top of that all that
quantitative easing all those asset
purchases they're gonna brag about the
fact that they're gonna bring down that
federal reserve balance sheet [ __ ]
there's no way that they're going to be
able to do this for a prolonged period
of time you can see in the past that
there's been short periods of time where
they've started to actually bring it
down but then of course there's this
explosive nature to that balance sheet
what we ultimately get is a continued
increase in the fed's balance sheet
today we're talking about closing in on
nine trillion eventually in the future
decades from now we'll be talking about
90 trillion dollars on the fed's balance
sheet why not because 90 trillion
dollars in today's terms instead what
we'll be talking about is 90 trillion
dollars with a devalued currency because
there's one thing guaranteed in the
financial markets and that's they have
to continue to devalue the currency they
have to devalue your savings in order to
keep this whole charade going so
ultimately regardless of what happens in
the short term if you're a long-term
investor remember the fed they've gotta
continue to have low rates they have to
continue asset purchases and you can't
taper this nonsense and ultimately the
long term bull market will still be
intact they have absolutely outlawed
bear markets they have banned market
corrections this is all short-lived [ __ ]
and if you're a long-term young person
then you know what to do it's a secular
multi-decade trend just get behind the
trend the trend is your friend get long
get loud and let the fed make you richer
than you ever imagined what do you guys
think about this
yeah i mean yeah i agree with most of
that i think uh ultimately like one of
the interesting things to me was how he
talked about inflation he said yeah
obviously we think there's risk there is
risk the upside we have to be aware of
everything do we think that's the base
case no we think inflation is going to
get better over the next year or two and
like everyone sounds that sounds amazing
right inflation's going to go down all
these things but like inflation was
never going to compound at 10 to 15
year-over-year for multiple consecutive
years right like that's just not uh in
the cards that it's not possible unless
things get really really really bad so
if inflation comes down three percent
four percent five percent like it's
still bad on a year-over-year basis uh
the number is just coming down so i
think that's one thing for sure and then
the other point yeah like i don't see
there's like like we said the other day
some people are estimating seven rate
hikes this year that that is absolutely
absurd i don't think that's going to
happen at all i think they'll start to
hike in in march the markets will uh
certainly have a reaction to that like
we've seen over the past few weeks and
then everything after that is like to be
determined in my opinion i don't think
they have any real idea of kind of what
they're going to do on a monetary policy
front and i think we're going to see
that the markets are going to react
negatively and stuff and it's probably
going to change their long-term course
john
yeah i mean this is uh one it's a very
dinosaur like
process basically the markets are
reacting beforehand before the meeting
basically trying to anticipate what is
going to be expected of the fed and what
they're going to say
they went ahead and released markets
went down upon that release originally i
think the nasdaq was down around point
six percent uh the dow was down bitcoin
was down everything was down right they
did exactly i believe what everyone
expected them to say that they're still
gonna try to hike rates in march they're
gonna try to reduce their balance sheet
but
actions speak louder than words they
haven't done any of this stuff yet the
biggest thing that i think
was a mistake that he said or that i
don't really agree with is that we're at
maximum employment where the hell did
you get that number who told you that
number we are not at maximum employment
based off what we've seen the last two
years we're nowhere close to it um we're
definitely growing through our
unemployment numbers but we're
definitely not at maximum employment
employment so i i don't know what people
expected to get from this meeting and
from these notes i think it was very
well scripted he told people exactly
what they wanted to hear but actions
speak louder than words
we'll see what they end up doing but i
don't like the chances of them actually
following through with the majority of
this over the medium term right they
will raise rates at some point this year
i do believe that but i think that
ultimately what people have to remember
is that inflation is narrative driven
and so if you start to talk about
inflation a bunch then people start
acting they move their capital in
advance they go ahead and they raise
prices that drives inflation higher and
so the same thing happens here the more
they talk about hey we're going to taper
we're going to raise interest rates
we're going to do this we talk tough we
talk tough we talk tough people start to
move capital you've seen it already
right tech stocks growth stocks crypto
et cetera they all sold off in
anticipation of an interest rate uh
decision or in anticipation of an asset
purchase taper but ultimately what ends
up happening is a lot of the talking
tough ends up being uh more of the
strategy than actually doing things and
they're trying to use language and
they're trying to use uh kind of the
fear-mongering to actually get people to
bring the market back down and so it's
happening to some degree but the
question is how long can they use
talking versus doing in order to
continue to impact the market in a
sustainable way i don't think it's very
long so the other thing when it comes to
maximum employment too is like they they
have two mandates right it's price
stability maximum employment and you
can't do price stability you can't
correct that unless maximum employment
they've already said this we need to get
maximum employment under control or at
least towards our standard of maximum
employment before we attack price
stability and price stability really
what they're going to do is just start
raising interest rates right so
i think that was like a precursor and a
requirement for them to do the second
and start to attack price stability so
even if that is not completely correct
and they feel that they need to go uh
start to work on price stability and get
inflation under control then they were
going to say that anyway so ultimately
whether you know all 22 million jobs or
whatever that were wiped out during the
pandemic are refilled that's obviously
not the case but ultimately like they
had to do that before they start to
attack price stability so whether it's
true or not like i think they were
always going to say that so current
unemployment is 3.9 percent uh pre-pain
is 3.5
it's like i'm not a mathematician but i
think that's more than 10 higher than it
used to be pre pandemic so like yeah
sure if it goes down to 3.5 which by the
way was a historical low right we were
near a historical low but like that
would be the point at which you could
say okay we got back to pre-pandemic
levels of unemployment but we're not
there and yet at the same time these
guys are running around uh all over the
internet uh the current administration
they're celebrating so we're the
strongest economy ever we created more
jobs than any president in the in the
world but all this crazy nonsense and
ultimately what ends up happening is
they're claiming victory but the data
still isn't showing anything and so you
can't just say oh we're at maximum
employment because uh we are close or
we're much better than we were right
remember 2007 2008 2009 there was
incredible unemployment uh in the united
states and it took literally a decade
almost to get all the way back down uh
to about 3.5 3.7 percent unemployment we
still aren't there now the the return
back under 4 has been much more rapid or
kind of severe uh in terms of the
ability to get back to uh to under four
percent unemployment but we're still not
the three point five percent i don't
think you can claim victory until you
get back to where we were before the
pandemic yeah and then 45 basis points
doesn't sound like that much but it's
millions of jobs right so it yeah
there's still six million people who are
unemployed yeah so in that context it's
much worse the best tool i think the fed
has right now they can raise interest
rates they can reduce their balance
sheet they can do all these things uh
but they are controlling the narrative
right now and they are basically um the
final word here so i think controlling
the narrative moving forward is going to
be a key thing to look for for them and
what are they saying um but then
ultimately what are they doing after the
fact and are they actually doing what
they're saying they're gonna do